Muy bien, obtengamos un poco más de práctica
calculando límites de funciones compuestas. En
este caso queremos encontrar el lim x → -1 g
(h(x)) y podemos ver la función g definida de
manera gráfica por aquí, a la izquierda, mientras
que podemos ver la función h definida de manera
gráfica por aquí, a la derecha. Pausa el video
e inténtalo por tu cuenta. Muy bien, seguramente
tu primera intención fue decir "Ok, ¿cuál es
el límite cuando x se aproxima a -1 h((x))? Y
si es que existe ese límite, entonces pondré ese
valor en g". Bueno, si tomamos el límite cuando
x → -1 de h(x), podemos ver que tenemos un límite
distinto cuando nos aproximamos desde la derecha
que cuando nos aproximamos desde la izquierda,
así que tal vez estés tentado a rendirte en este
momento. Pero lo que haremos en este video es
darnos cuenta de que, el límite de esta función
compuesta realmente existe a pesar de que el
límite cuando x → -1 h(x) no exista. Así que,
¿cómo lo encontramos? Lo que podemos hacer
es tomar los límites por la izquierda y
por la derecha. Primero pensemos en cuál es el
límite cuando x → -1 por la derecha de... bueno,
de g(h(x)). Bueno, para pensar en esto tenemos
que encontrar cuál es el límite de h cuando x →
-1 por la derecha. Si nos aproximamos a -1 por la
derecha, parece que h se aproxima a -2. Otra forma
de verlo es que esto será igual al limite h(x) →
-2 y ¿desde qué dirección se aproxima a -2? Bueno,
se aproxima a -2 desde valores más grandes que
-2, h(x) está decreciendo hasta -2 cuando x → -1
desde la derecha, por lo tanto, nos aproximamos
desde valores más grandes que -2, y, bueno,
de g(h(x)), de g(h(x)). Vamos a ponerle el mismo código decolor para que sea más fácil darle seguimiento.
Así que esto es análogo a decir ¿cuál es el
límite de g cuando x → -2 desde la derecha?
Aquí h es sólo la entrada de la función g, así
que la entrada de g se aproxima a -2 desde arriba,
desde valores más grandes que -2, desde la
derecha, y podemos ver que g se aproxima a 3,
así que esto de aquí será igual a 3. Ahora tomemos
el límite cuando x → -1 desde la izquierda de
g(h(x)). Bueno, primero podemos pensar ¿a qué
se aproxima h cuando x → -1 por la izquierda?
Cuando x → -1 desde la izquierda, parece que
h se aproxima a -3, así que podemos decir que
esto es igual al lim h(x) → -3, y observa: se
aproxima a -3 desde valores más grandes que -3,
es decir, h(x) se aproxima a -3 desde arriba
o desde valores más grandes que -3, de, bueno,
nos falta, g(h(x)). Otra forma de pensar en
esto es ¿cuál es el límite cuando la entrada
de g se aproxima a -3 desde la derecha? Bueno,
cuando nos aproximamos a -3 desde la derecha,
g está justo aquí en 3, así que de nuevo esto
será igual a 3. Entonces, observa: en este caso,
el límite por la derecha y el límite por la
izquierda son iguales a 3, y cuando el límite
por la derecha y el límite por la izquierda son
iguales, sabemos que el límite que buscábamos es
igual a ese valor, es igual a 3. Y este es
un ejemplo genial, ya que podemos decir que
el límite de la función interna h(x) no existe,
pero sí existe el límite de la función compuesta.